violette 10 ans profite d'une permission
spéciale elle peut utiliser sa tablette
en pleine semaine normalement son père
le lui interdit entre autres pour éviter
que sa myopie s'accentue nous on ne
signale parce que tu es jeune assemien
plissée dès l'âge de 5 ans ses parents
ont détecté certains problèmes de la
vision envoie une épidémie de l'ami
appuie donc beaucoup plus de cas qui
nous arrive est à un âge beaucoup plus
jeune le nombre de mire a doublé en
amérique dans les vingt dernières années
regarde à gauche la myopie apparaît
maintenant dès l'âge de 6 ans dans les
années 90 c'était généralement autour de
la puberté
samir pioche j'étais quand même assez
rapidement seces a conçu comme ça va se
ramasser avec 1 - d'auge -14 de dire
trim et c'est justement ce qui inquiète
les scientifiques atteindre un niveau de
myopie sévère rapidement la
préoccupation actuellement à travers le
monde c'est empêcher les jeunes myope
d'atteindre ce niveau où il devient à
risques de pathologies
ça peut aller jusqu'à la cécité quand la
partie centrale de lyon la macula est
atteint simon bourdeau et sa conjointe
sont tous deux mis hop
si le facteur héréditaire est
déterminant l'utilisation des écrans y
est aussi pour beaucoup
l'écran lui-même n'émet pas de
radiations nocives
c'est le fait de travailler souvent et
beaucoup dans des environnements qui
simule beaucoup d'endroits différents
distance tablettes téléphones
intelligents ordinateur l'oeil se
fatigue plus rapidement dans cet
environnement multimédia
violette peut en témoigner j'ai envie de
faire les messieurs souvent sapé qui
chagrine beaucoup des yeux pour ralentir
la progression de ces myopie elle porte
des lentilles de contact plus
performantes que les lunettes l'ovaire
de contact en or tout cas la théologie
ont prouvé sur plusieurs années qu'on
pouvait ralentir de 30 à 40 % la
progression de la myopie même si le ms
estime que le problème a pris des
proportions de pandémie dans certaines
régions du monde
la myopie n'est toujours pas reconnu
comme un enjeu de santé publique au
québec et au canada
on ne sait même pas combien d'enfants
sont myope selon des optométristes un
enfant sur quatre en seraient atteints
aux primaires et si mme montembeault
phrase au canada trois rivières